2010 年的《社群網戰》
把祖克柏創辦臉書的過程搬上大銀幕
劇本拿下奧斯卡
寫劇本的人叫 Aaron Sorkin
影集《白宮風雲》也是他寫的
人物講話又快又密是他的招牌
16 年後他又拍了一部臉書的電影
叫 The Social Reckoning
主角換成臉書的吹哨者跟報導她的記者
美國 10 月 9 號上映
這是紐約時報 9 月上架的訪談
他在裡面說他對 AI 很樂觀
因為他覺得 AI 不會成功
訪談先談的是祖克柏
Sorkin 說，真人寫進劇本
寫到後來都會變成他自己創造的角色
不過講到祖克柏，《社群網戰》跟 The Social Reckoning 兩部都一樣，
寫任何一個反英雄也一樣，祖克柏就是反英雄
他不是反派
有些人可能分不清楚，在你心裡，反英雄跟反派差在哪裡？
反英雄的出發點是好的，他們認為自己在做好事
像《軍官與魔鬼》裡 Jack Nicholson 演的角色，那是我寫的第一部作品
他那一整段演說，講的就是他認為自己在保護美國
企鵝人、小丑，他們只想統治高譚市
那種才是反派，其他的是反英雄
寫祖克柏，或者寫任何一個反英雄，
我是寫的人，我不能去評判這個角色
我寫他的時候，是當作他正在向上帝陳述，自己為什麼該上天堂
你不覺得祖克柏是反派？
妳問的是真的祖克柏，還是我寫的祖克柏？
你說說看，差別在哪裡
好。真的祖克柏我不想評斷，我不是為了這個來的
The Social Reckoning 裡的祖克柏是反英雄，不是反派
我還想補一句，替這個角色跟他本人辯護的，不只我一個
演他的 Jeremy Strong，這個角色他演得太精彩了，
他一直在跟我替祖克柏辯護，不只在片場，半夜還會寫信給我
他殺青那天，最後一個鏡頭一拍完，
我才剛喊完卡、喊完檢查片門，
Jeremy Strong 就大步走過來，那是我第一次在片場聽到他用自己的聲音講話，
不是祖克柏的聲音，是他自己的聲音
他說，如果我演的是記者 Jeff，我就會替 Jeff 辯護
而我現在完全知道，祖克柏會怎麼向上帝陳述
我的意思是…
他在拉近人跟人的距離
這從一開始就是他的使命
我猜他現在推的那些技術，像 AI，還有那副蠢眼鏡，
在他的想像裡，都是帶著所有人往前走
主持人後來問到他怎麼寫作
Sorkin 寫對白的時候會站起來
把整場戲演一遍，邊演邊唸
他說，那是寫得順的日子
我愛寫作，我討厭的是寫不出來
偏偏對我來說，寫作大部分的時間都是寫不出來
大部分時間我都急得快抓狂，走來走去，腦袋空空
我每次都覺得，自己再也想不出下一個點子了
《白宮風雲》我寫了 88 集，其中有 87 次，
我都跟身邊的人說，各位，到此為止了
我會的每一個字，我想得到的每一種排法，全都用完了
我沒有故事可以講了，我們麻煩大了
寫電影的時候這樣，寫舞台劇的時候還是這樣
你寫的對白風格非常好認，對吧？
一群超聰明的人，用超快的速度，互丟超聰明的俏皮話
現在談創意、談寫作，AI 當然是個大議題
你有沒有動過念頭，去找個聊天機器人，叫它寫一場 Aaron Sorkin 風格的戲？
因為我想像得到，這種指令它們一定知道要怎麼模仿
講著講著，我自己都想去試了
不是啦，我是說模仿，沒有說它寫得比你好
我想機器人大概做得到妳說的…
不不不，我說的是模仿，因為你的風格非常鮮明
這種指令它們看得懂
謝謝妳這樣說。沒有，我沒試過
不過妳想不想聽我的理論…想不想聽我為什麼對 AI 樂觀？
想
好。因為我覺得它不會成功
我記得前陣子去參加一場晚宴，
牆上掛了一幅畫，是抽象畫
我還滿喜歡的，就一直看…我對藝術一竅不通
「抽象」這個詞講出來，我會的詞彙就用完了
但我喜歡那幅畫，我也說不上來
人應該從藝術得到的那個東西，當下正在發生。我喜歡它
然後晚宴的主人走過來跟我說：「那是機器畫的」
我很佩服這個技術，可是我對那幅畫的感覺，不管那是什麼，就這樣沒了
如果你有在打電動，如果你玩《決勝時刻》，
你在《決勝時刻》裡開槍打的那些人，你對他們不會有感情，
看 AI 做的《辛德勒的名單》，就會是這種感受
我想我們以後會發現，你走進電影院的時候，
你可能不知道導演是誰，不知道編劇是誰，
也不知道演員叫什麼名字
但我想我們會發現，那是人做的，這件事對你很重要
可是到處都有人在用這項技術抄捷徑，跳過那段辛苦的過程，
就是你為了想出一個點子，要熬的那一段
我相信妳說的。而且老實講，我要想出一個點子、要起個頭，本來就那麼難，
所以老實講，如果我去其中一個網站，跟它說，
欸，幫個忙，幫我寫一場開場戲，故事是關於…
它要是真的寫得出來，甚至只是寫得八九不離十，
到我只需要把對白稍微潤一下的程度，
那我以後大概就只會做這件事了
我想我再也不會自己去想點子了
危險就在這裡
嗯，對
那你為什麼還樂觀？
首先，我是靠這個吃飯的，好嗎？
Lulu，別再想辦法說服我失業了，好不好？
不過我是真心相信…一開始我想的是，好吧，
也許以後不是 AI 做的電影，只有藝術戲院才看得到
偶爾會聽說，哪個小鎮有一家很棒的戲院，專門放不是 AI 做的片子
但我不相信會這樣
我要看史柯西斯的電影，我要看史匹柏的電影，
我要看 Adam McKay 的電影，我要看 Greta Gerwig 的電影
我對 AI 電影的感覺，會跟我對那幅 AI 畫的感覺一模一樣
Sorkin 自己也承認
AI 要是寫得出一場像樣的開場戲
他大概就不會再自己想點子了
他還是相信，觀眾走進戲院的時候
會在乎那部電影是人做的
原影片一個小時
Sorkin 還講到
據他了解 Meta 寄過信給出品這部片的 Sony
片廠另外請了一家律師事務所
把電影裡講到的事實一條一條核對過
他也講了 2019 年他在紐約時報寫公開信批評臉書
祖克柏拿他寫過的電影台詞來回應
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。